Even with all the publicity she's received
since Game of Thrones premiered, there are
still plenty of fun facts and discoveries
to be made about the talented actress Emilia
Clarke, a singular talent who still has an
extraordinary future ahead of her. Here are
just a few of the untold truths about Clarke's
life and career.
Thanks to her starring role in HBO's massive
hit series Game of Thrones, Emilia Clarke
has become one of the most recognizable faces
on television.
Beyond Game of Thrones, Clarke has appeared
in other high-profile roles too, including
star turns in films like Solo: A Star Wars
Story and Terminator Genisys. So far, her
most significant role has certainly been Daenerys
Targaryen, otherwise known as Khaleesi and
the Mother of Dragons.
Game of Thrones is a notoriously fleshy adventure
series, and Emilia Clarke racked up quite
a few nude scenes during the show's first
season. In 2017, she told Actors on Actors:
"The naked stuff is always difficult… it's
always kind of hard because it's just… uncomfortable
for many, many, many, many reasons."
As she told Entertainment Weekly, her life
took a turn for the incredibly awkward when
she wound up watching one of those nude scenes
with her family. Whoops.
"I ended up sitting them down and being like,
‘Let’s watch it’ — and then instantly
regretting it. … My dad was like, ‘Again?'”
Graham Norton was clearly tickled by that
anecdote:
"Did you watch it with your parents?"
"Yes."
Clarke also had no qualms about appearing
nude on stage in a production of Breakfast
at Tiffany's, which premiered at New York's
Cort Theater in 2013. Naturally, a big name
like Clarke drew huge crowds, including some
exceedingly creepy patrons who took photos
of Clarke during her nude scenes.
Unfortunately, the show was slammed by critics
and closed after only 38 performances. It's
too bad her first theatrical outing was tarnished
by weird audience members and bad reviews...
but at least now she has a Broadway credit
to her name, and there will likely be many
more in the future.
After her breakout role on Game of Thrones,
Clarke was inundated with film offers, with
one big franchise standing out from the pack.
Reportedly, Clarke was offered the lead role
of Anastasia Steele in Fifty Shades of Grey,
the first in a trilogy of theoretically sexy
films based on the bestselling series of trashy
novels.
Ultimately, Clarke decided to turn down the
role, which famously went to Dakota Johnson,
who starred alongside British actor Jamie
Dornan for the entirety of the series.
In a 2015 interview with Kiss FM, Clarke played
a little bit coy about the decision:
"Is it true that you turned down the Fifty
Shades of Grey role?"
"Ooooh… well! Uhhhhh… ay-juh… Yeah."
Clarke has explained why she made that decision.
Fifty Shades could have certainly given her
more exposure as an actor, but it wasn't the
kind of exposure she wanted. After her history
of nude scenes on stage and screen, Clarke
didn't want to be labeled as any specific
type of performer. She says she really doesn't
regret turning down the role. Considering
the bleak critical reception the trilogy received,
it seems like she definitely made the right
choice.
Add Emilia Clarke's name to the long, illustrious
list of tattooed celebrities. Clarke's first
tattoo was dedicated to her role in Me Before
You, where she played a big-hearted caretaker
who has a tattoo of a bumblebee. Well, guess
what Clarke got inked on her pinky finger?
"I got a bumblebee."
"And what is that?"
"It's so badass. Badass girl, you got a tattoo,
what'd you get? A bumblebee. There's still
plaster on it."
Naturally, Clarke needed to get a Game of
Thrones tattoo, too. And guess what she went
for this time?
"I was in a tattoo parlor the other day trying
to make an appointment, and they said they
were full because you're coming in to get
a tattoo of a dragon?"
"Yes."
Maybe they aren't the biggest dragons we've
ever seen. But they are dragons.
Clarke was seemingly born to be an actor,
considering that her father worked in the
theater community in London as a sound engineer.
The first show Clarke ever saw as a child
was Showboat. She was enthralled, falling
in love with the theater right then and there.
However, her dad wasn't quite so enthusiastic
about her goals. In fact, he took her to a
real audition in the West End in the hopes
of scaring her away from the profession. She
bombed completely, showing up unprepared with
just a folk song to her name.
As she continued pursuing her dream, Clarke
said her dad's only advice was to be aware
of the many pitfalls of the profession. He
reminded her that actors rarely make a living
off their passion and even told her that the
only line she ever needed to memorize was:
"Do you want fries with that?"
We're sure her dad had the best intentions,
but fans around the world must be glad Clarke
kept at it. She eventually attended the prestigious
Drama Centre London, and the rest is history.
Well, more or less...
After graduating, Clarke's acting career got
off to a rather quiet start. She had a few
bit parts in commercials and made appearances
on British shows like Doctors and even a dreadful
SyFy original movie called Triassic Attack.
In 2010, Screen International named her one
of the "UK Stars of Tomorrow," and they were
right on the money: She scored her audition
for Game of Thrones shortly after that career
milestone.
But Clarke still had to make sure her bills
were paid. At the time she landed the role,
Clarke was reportedly working six jobs, including
a gig as a real estate agent.
Due to the importance of that particular audition,
Clarke called in sick to her catering job
that day. Obviously her efforts were well
worth it, as she booked the role of a lifetime
and quickly became one of the most celebrated
young actresses in the industry. Take that,
catering job.
The fact that Clarke even got to audition
for Game of Thrones is rather extraordinary,
considering the pilot had already been shot
by the time she got that fateful call from
her agent. However, the original pilot was
a dismal failure. Before you think that's
too harsh a description, it comes from series
creators David Benioff Benioff and D.B. Weiss,
who blamed unclear storytelling, melodramatic
death scenes, and bad casting. They eventually
reshot about ninety percent of the episode.
The creators have politely declined to discuss
why they recast the role of Daenerys, which
was originally played by actress Tamzin Merchant,
best known for roles like Catherine Howard
on The Tudors. The original pilot never saw
the light of day, and now it's impossible
to imagine anyone but Clarke playing Daenerys.
Over the course of seven seasons, she's been
nominated for several Emmy awards and has
made the role completely her own. She'll probably
be referred to as the "Mother of Dragons"
for many more years to come.
Emilia Clarke is the first to admit that her
Game of Thrones audition took an odd turn.
Prior to her audition, she'd spent hours scouring
Wikipedia to learn more about A Song of Ice
and Fire, George R. R. Martin's book series
on which Game of Thrones is based.
As she told Jimmy Fallon, showrunners Benioff
and Weiss asked Clarke about her other talents
after she read a few lines of dialogue. Then
they suggested that she do a dance.
"I just… I don't know how to do it, but
I did the Funky Chicken. And it kind of morphed
into The Robot… And I sort of heard, I heard
some laughter going on…"
Afterwards, she evidently didn't feel particularly
hopeful about the audition. Of course, she
was cast in the role shortly afterwards.
Clarke may have gotten giggles out of the
showrunners, but they still got a taste of
the remarkable intensity she uses to bring
Daenerys to life. In fact, it sounds like
they were completely sold on her right out
of the gate.
"Our certitude was as religious as Daenerys's:
She was the one."
Until recently, Emilia Clarke kept one period
of her life completely private. In a moving
personal essay published in The New Yorker
in March 2019, she revealed that she'd survived
a very serious health scare. During a session
with her personal trainer, Clarke suffered
a debilitating brain aneurysm. Only a third
of patients survive what she endured.
After a minimally invasive form of brain surgery,
Clarke learned that she had a smaller aneurysm
elsewhere in her brain that could also pop.
Shaky, exhausted, and partially reliant on
morphine, Clarke bravely went back to work
and continued filming Game of Thrones. Then,
in 2013, the second aneurysm burst, requiring
a much more invasive surgery. An incredibly
difficult road to recovery lay ahead.
"The second one, a bit of my brain actually
died. If a part of your brain doesn't get
blood to it for a minute, it will just no
longer work."
In her essay, Clarke writes that she's now,
quote, "one hundred percent" recovered. She
also started a charity called SameYou to help
patients suffering from strokes and other
brain injuries. As a professional actress
and public figure, Clarke's brave decision
to speak out about the most difficult period
of her life speaks volumes about her character.
Despite her personal successes, 2016 was a
difficult year for the young star. In the
aftermath of Brexit, an issue near and dear
to Clarke's heart as a Londoner, she lost
a family member shortly after the vote, and
both situations set her adrift personally
and professionally.
Clarke's father had suffered from cancer for
years and succumbed to his illness in July
2016. Sadly, she couldn't be there during
his final days. While his health declined,
she was filming a movie in Kentucky. After
cutting the filming short, she finally arrived
in London only to learn that he'd already
passed away. This was absolutely devastating
to Clarke, especially since she was due back
on the Game of Thrones set in three weeks.
She told Rolling Stone that the experience
only made her stronger. Since her father's
death, she's praised the nurses who cared
for him, vowing that she'd always support
England's medical community from that day
forward. In 2018, she became an ambassador
for London's Royal College of Nursing, joining
in the school's ongoing campaign for financial
support from the British government and the
NHS.
When a cast is sworn to secrecy while filming
one of the world's hottest shows in far-flung
locations, it's only natural that they'd become
close friends. Clarke is no exception. Daenerys
started off the series with a wedding to Khal
Drogo, played by future Aquaman star Jason
Momoa. The two became fast friends while they
were quartered in Morocco together.
Though Drogo was dead by the end of the first
season, Momoa and Clarke have remained very
close. In fact, they refer to each other as,
quote, "the moon of my life" and "my sun and
stars." To this day, Momoa seems like one
of Clarke's biggest supporters, and fans are
always delighted by their reunions, which
have taken place at major award shows and
Comic-Con, where Momoa made a surprise appearance
that did indeed succeed in startling Clarke.
Now, as the show ends, Clarke will almost
certainly be closing out her character's storyline
alongside Kit Harington. He of course plays
the brooding Jon Snow, the presumed bastard
who is actually Daenerys' royal nephew and
her new lover. Yup. Luckily, she and Harington
seem to be having a great time together on
set, especially when they're joking around
about their love scenes.
"I mean I think 'ughhh' might be the reaction."
"I like looking at her and going 'Ugh, god,
I'm sorry.'"
The pair have been friends since the first
season, and each of them is excited to finish
the series with a friend at their side.
As Daenerys, Clarke is no stranger to traveling
through foreign lands, often on foot. At the
beginning of Game of Thrones, she begins a
long journey from the native land of the Dothraki
warrior clan, located across the Narrow Sea
from Westeros, in order to finally take back
the Iron Throne of the Seven Kingdoms.
She gets turned around several times over,
ending up in Slaver's Bay and subsequently
taking control of several slave cities before
finally ending up in Westeros in the seventh
season. Thanks to this storyline, Clarke herself
has gotten to travel to several exotic filming
locations over the years, including Croatia,
Ireland, Iceland, and Spain.
Like her character, Clarke became a world
traveler at a young age. At just 16, she embarked
on a backpacking trip through Northern India,
continuing into Tibet, having made the journey
to scatter the ashes of her grandmother, who
was born in Delhi. A few years later, she
made a similar journey through Southeast Asia
as well as South Africa, proving that she's
just as adventurous as her signature character.
No surprise there!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one.